The process of finding the right
investor is not an easy one.
I think it really begins in
understanding who are the investors that
are going to be
attracted to what you do.
So, for example, you can go out and
find investors that like your domain.
They have invested in companies in your
space, not in a competitor of yours,
but in your type of technology or
business.
And perhaps,
they would have the propensity and
the interest to invest in you.
So, making out that list,
you can search on Angie's List and
CrunchBase and other free data sources
out there to find those investors.
That would be number one.
Number two is,
I think people that perhaps you've come,
throughout your career,
perhaps working in an early stage
startup and you were an early employee.
And maybe there's an investor
that invested in that company.
Maybe those are investors that
invested in your friends, right?
People that actually can look at you and
know that what you've done before this
startup is something quite amazing.
And they might want to invest in you
going forward, because of who you are,
because they believe in you.
So, looking at investors in your domain,
looking at investors that
share the same career path with you, or
invested in startups you work with, and
then reaching out to investors
that maybe your friends know,
that invested in their businesses,
that your friends can vouch for
you when they make the introduction
to those investors.